hey welcome back I'm Jesse I'm here at
the Wolfram tech conference 2017 and for
those that are just tuning in I'm just
talking with interesting people who are
using our technology and pretty cool
ways I'm here with AB Rita and she's
gonna tell us a little bit about what
she does here at Wolfram and what she's
doing here at the conference so okay
yeah so um I work in a balloon
technology group and so we do two things
two kinds of things primarily like
technical support to users of the motion
technology and that spans a huge
spectrum of users from different areas
and so it's it's interesting trying to
help on people you know one day you're
working with someone in academia who is
using this for something hard called
physics or mathematical risk research
and then the other day you're working
with someone you know who is a web
developer and is trying to deploy stuff
in the cloud and they need some help so
that's one aspect of the work we do at
technical support I work alongside a
team of very talented engineers from
very different backgrounds from computer
science applied math
nuclear physics yeah we do have someone
and fantastic to work in a team and on
the other side I work for wolfing
training I'm trying to work with work
from you
that's happen coming we are trying to
put together courses that people will
find useful and helpful where we apply
more from technology but we also want to
help people out to learn whatever it is
they want to learn whether it's you know
just basic math or data science or you
know image processing or neural networks
so we try to talk a little bit about the
topic and then we bring in how you can
use little technology to do all this
stuff
so offer view kind of hosts a wide
breadth the kind of topics that span
from like introductory language deep
learning and using your networks cool
yeah well um so what are you doing here
at level from tech conference alright so
I taught a course on data science we
broke it up into two parts so we had one
part in the morning and one part in the
afternoon the idea was to introduce
people to the notion of a pipeline that
you know that you sort of a project
workflow to go through a data science
project from beginning to end and show
how you could use Wolfram language like
it's perfectly poised to be used in a
data science pipeline because we can do
everything from getting the data into
the system to publishing you know
stunning visualizations or deploying
apps on the web you can do it all in the
world from technology and so we want to
highlight that aspect while giving
people tips and tricks that are useful
in a data science project so do you have
a visual of the kind of prototype to
deployment pipeline that that kind of
sure so this is one of the pipe a
picture of the pipeline that I shared
with the attendees at my course and I
wanted to show that that this is one
version of the pipeline this is how I
see it of course there are so many other
version like you know depending on your
project workflow like you might want to
do something first and something later
but this I suggested that you know you
start out with a question that you have
that data can help you answer and then
you go out and collect data for it or
you might already have some interesting
data and you want to think what
interesting questions can I answer with
the help of this data so you start off
with your question you get the data in
and so then you start it off on the
pipeline so you start with the face
that's called wrangling the data because
you know real world data is messy oh
yeah and and a lot of the people who
were in the course they completely agree
that here we've had trouble and data
scientists really say that they spent
almost 80% of their time in this space
which is boring and it has to be done
before you can go on to the interesting
part of making your models so I love
that it's called I mean I'm from Texas
so these values exactly that's the
picture you know is a lot of time is
just hacking away at it because you
don't know what's in there you want to
put it in the right format so you start
out with data wrangling and then you go
into data cleaning you want to get rid
of errors and you know missing data a
lot of times stuff is not there and you
have to come up with a plan how you're
going to replace it or you just want to
throw it away stuff that has missing
data in it so then you go into that and
then you go into exploratory analysis
because a lot of times before jumping
into modeling you want to you know
trying to feel fine you're
fine which way things are going get like
a picture of that I mean literally look
at the data you can use and and
sometimes you come up with interesting
questions at that phase that here never
thought of this but I can see this in
the picture so that would be exploring
and then you go into modeling
pre-processing more theoretical stuff
that you know we have established
technology for what exactly what is
pre-processing I I've never I don't
really know much about ok how it works
versus processing data sure sure
so for example like you know if you're
working with images as your primary data
you can't just work off the images you
know a lot of times if you're doing
things like machine learning things like
clustering where you want to find you
know how close certain images are so
there comes the notion of distance
between the images now how do you
slightly the distance between two
pictures right right so you convert the
image into numerical vectors so the
images become numbers Oh
basically the pixel values right so you
have the now that you have the vectors
and now you can calculate the
mathematical distance between them with
something as simple as like the
Euclidean distance function or you know
anything more complicated that is
specific to your knee but now this step
are you're going from the image to a
number vector this is pre-processing
this is feature extraction we have a
great like function for that you have
the feature extract function and we have
some variations of it and I try to talk
about that in my courses like quick and
easy way you don't have to write your
own for the use of a feature extract
function and you can go from one for
more feature to another and then also
there is a dimension reduction which is
very important in machine learning and
data science because you you know you're
flooded with data you have lots and lots
of features
you can't possibly use all of it you
want to get it down to a reasonable you
know way that you can handle and then
also if you want to look at the data you
want it in two dimensions right you
cannot plot it in five dimensions so two
or three dimensions so that's where
dimensionality reduction comes in and we
have functions for that so you can
quickly and you have
established algorithms built in that you
can use and you can dimension reduce so
so it seems like this whole this whole
high-level process kind of it's
decreased with the amount of sort of
automation that yes that's the idea that
you want to automate as much as possible
because you want to produce a little
research you want to run this pipeline
over and over again and so that's why we
are you know we we are saying that this
is the pipeline automated scripted right
as much code as you can don't go like
point-and-click and garden you know so
that okay now I kind of understand what
FTN was talking about yesterday with the
fully automated data scientist this is
kind of what I mean he had an example of
like a baker but this kind of is a
little bit more concrete it makes a
little bit more sense yeah and then just
to end the pipeline of course you have
to validate and you know make sure your
model is doing what you hope it will do
but at the end of it which I feel is
really important is to tell the story
like you can do all the analysis but you
know it's not useful if you can get your
message across right and to get your
message across you want an efficient and
actually sometimes a beautiful way to do
it you want a pretty fixture that you
know someone can look at the picture and
they know what
what's your tub trying to tell them and
that's where our technology comes in so
nicely because we can make really good
visualizations and it's all in there you
get the data and the results of analysis
you make these quick nice beautiful
plots whether it's just you know a trend
or you know it's the evaluation of your
model like like a crowd you know
confusion plot matrix it's anything like
that or I know and I was actually
talking say is sharing an anecdote at my
course that you know when I was in
graduate school just to make that
confusion plant matrix look nice and
share it with my advisor I spent two
days coding it and then I used like our
machine learning function and when you
you just provide it as an option we say
okay confusion plot matrix and boom bins
there
thanks so much easier to aim it like not
just visualizations we also have
technology for like standalone app like
a CDF
and also I was saying that you know if
you want to deploy your little
classifier on the web so we you can
deploy it as a cloud object and so we
have this little micro site and actually
for my course I used the example of
classifying recipes based on ingredients
and so what I did was I created a tiny
side where you just type in the
ingredient and it will classify the
cuisine and then I put in a link to like
a recipe website then it gives you a
suggestion
okay this is the ingredient in your
pantry then you can cook probably oh my
god that would be so helpful for me I
mean I live in a house with a bunch of
other people we have to work at least
once a week and half the time like I
don't even know like I get into the
kitchen to cook and it's like what do we
have and then I figure out what we have
I'm like I don't know what to make I'm
going to make with it that's one way of
actually you know you do all the
analysis that's one way you put it out
into the world for people to use so
that's what you call creating a data
product and that's like at the end of
your pipeline so you know oneself this
is how I'm telling the story of
classifying the cuisine of the you know
with the ingredients and so now I have
the actionable insight that is you okay
you getting stuff out of your pantry and
you know using the product to cook I
love that you mentioned CDF technology
can you tell me well just in case like
our viewers don't know what CDF is can
you kind of talk a little bit about it
how it's like useful yeah and they have
had a few talks at the conference and I
think I'll have one more right after in
a few
about C D F so C D F stands for
computational computable document format
so where it's like you know living
documents where it's not just like you
know static papers but you actually have
code an interaction built into it so you
can have like sort of a GUI where you
can play around with it so if you have
created and analysis for publication now
it doesn't have to be flat it can be
interactive so you can have controllers
on the QI so whoever is consuming the
result of your research they can play
around with parameters change things and
see how the analysis is changing things
change yeah thank you so much for
talking with me and thank you for having
me well like always if you have
questions about this particular
discussion with the frita or any others
just leave them in the comments of this
live stream we can't get to it during
this time but someone who can get back
to you later
also community debt will firm comm is a
great resource if you have any questions
someone might have already had it you
can also pose your own questions and
start a discussion and definitely check
out will from you if you're interested
in any of these like these data science
courses or image-processing there's a
lot of new interactive courses being
uploaded in the near future so
definitely check that out and thanks for
watching